[Musique]
bonjour elle verra masson et merci
d'avoir accepté ce grand entretien où on
va tenter d'explorer ensemble l'identité
européenne alors c'est grâce à
l'émission on va déguster de france
inter que beaucoup d'entre nous vaut
connaissent chroniqueuse culinaire vous
avez l'art de mettre nos sens en éveil
aujourd'hui on vous entend aussi dans
très très bon sur paris première on peut
mentionner que vous êtes également aux
tris du livre dans ma cuisine qui est un
gros succès et vous êtes également
rédactrice en chef adjointe de marie
claire vous aimez ce qui est bon vous
aimez ce qui est beau alors pourquoi
inviter une chroniqueuse culinaire quand
on parle d'identité européenne
on peut se dire que c'est saugrenue mais
en fait moi je trouve que c'est une très
bonne idée j'ai l'impression que
l'identité européenne elle passe pas mal
parce qu'on mange qu'est ce que vous en
pensez je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous tout d'abord bonjour et merci
beaucoup de me recevoir l'identité passe
réellement parce qu'on mange d'abord
parce que manger éventuellement cuisine
et s'alimenter c'est une pratique que
vous faites tous les jours quand on a la
chance de pouvoir le faire et elle est
fatalement nécessairement révélatrice
d'une histoire d'un passé d'une
construction et puis d'un comportement
d'une pratique sociale culturelle dont
ça paraît tout à fait évident que c'est
une idée tout à fait pertinente de
d'associer
cuisine et idée de l'europe et si on
parle de votre identité avoue plus
personnellement ça passe aussi en bonne
partie par ce que vous mangez ce que
vous avez mangé enfants par exemple je
me définis beaucoup part ça je sais j'ai
du mal à vraiment à
expliquer pourquoi je me définis ainsi
sans doute parce que ce que l'on
mangeait chez moi donc à la croisée des
chemins d'une identité effectivement
assez rhdp européenne un père français
et d'une mère suédoise ce qu'on mange
était assez
particulier alors on était loin de la
gastronomie on était loin de cette chose
gastronomie qui est la science du ventre
qui est qui relève d'une cuisine très
sophistiquée très codifié tel qu'un
vanté par de grands codificateur
français on était chez moi plutôt dans
un foyer voilà de cuisine quotidienne
simple sans prétention
assez terrienne terrestre rural un peu
paysanne qui piquent aurait un peu
partout en europe et pas qu'en europe
d'ailleurs donc ça allait de je ne sais
pas des poissons fumés marrainer des
origines suédoises de ma mère l'est -
jean suède
enfants en suède il y avait deux sets
suède pas mal dans l'assiette évidemment
beaucoup mais tu disais pas forcément
son nom s'était pas tiens on va faire un
repas suédois aujourd'hui mais ce qui
habitait la maison ce qui animait la
pièce cuisine
venait effectivement deux usages suédois
un peu quotidien confection des
boulettes de viande les fameuses chaque
but marqué pratiquement le plat national
suédois du saumon des poissons des
petits biscuits les pays scandinaves
comme les pays anglo saxons sont
vraiment des pays d'une pratique de bb
king quotidienne ça que c'est pas un
pays de tradition pâtissière à la
française très codifié comme ça encore
une fois avec des des gâteaux
architecture et non les pays scandinaves
et anglo-saxons le four est toujours
allumée ça sent les épices ya toujours
un gâteau ou un pain ou un biscuit en
train de cuire mais ça reste très très
simple que ça ces odeurs des pistes de
cannelle la viande pour les boulettes
les poissons c'était assez quotidien et
puis ça coexistaient avec plein d'autres
choses beaucoup de recettes italiennes
bizarrement mes parents avaient un
tropisme italien très forts dont j'ai
hérité encore une fois on parlait pas de
gastronomie ce n'était pas des grands
places étaient bien voilà on avait
appris à faire le pesto en italie donc
on le faisait en le mettez au
congélateur pour faisait l'été avec du
basilic frais on avait dupé stockant
j'adore tout toute l'année et
apparemment votre papa était capable
d'aller très loin pour chercher du
parmesan pour fabriquer ce pesto je suis
une enfant des années 80 c'est à dire
que le parmesan frais en france dans les
années 80 il n'y avait pas y avait des
sachets en plastique éventuellement avec
entrain par besoin voilà déshydraté que
t'es même pas forcément du fromage pas
trop ce que c'était et c'est va qui
avait cette idée du sourcing comme on
dit ou de l'approvisionnement en
produits
vraiment assez exigeants c'est à dire
qu'on allait faire venir effectivement
un bon fromage italien d'italie on
pouvait traverser paris pour aller
chercher tel ou tel produit mais c'était
pas du snobisme s'était pas à cette
espèce d'idée de ce n'était pas un code
bourgeois de on est bien et on est chic
parce qu'on est allé à tel endroit faire
ses courses il y avait l'idée quand même
je pense mais encore une fois ça n'était
pas nommé qu'il fallait respecter une
forme de chaînes de production vertueuse
ça ne m'était pas enseignée comme ça
mais on allait chez le fromager parce
que c'était chez le fromager qu'on
trouvait là ressources produites de
manière vertueuse c'est une forme
d'engagement écologique aussi dans ma
famille qui m'a été transmis encore une
fois sans que ce soit un vrai combat
mais le fait que vous ne mangez pas
nécessairement comme vos copines
justement vous mangiez c'est ses
boulettes et gâteaux à la cannelle tout
ça ça vous a fait prendre conscience à
un moment qu'il y avait justement une
identité particulière qui était la vôtre
parce que elle mêlait de la suède de la
france mais complètement j'en avais
aucune conscience moi même mais c'est au
contact d'autres enfants ou d'autres
ados que je me faisais mais tiens c'est
que c'est un peu étrange comme on chez
nous ça n'a rien à voir dans les
familles françaises je vais dire
classique sait pas on allait manger un
rôti avec des des flageolets ou des
haricots verts un peu trop cuit je
critique pas du tout la manière
française de 2,2
de consommer ou de d'ordonnancé sert pas
mais
qu'on s'imagine pas non plus et c'est
une tendance quand même un petit peu
franco française ça qu'on s'imagine pas
non plus qu'on mange divinement bien
dans tous les foyers français depuis
toujours un énorme patrimoine on a un
énorme patrimoine paysan notamment et
des vraies recettes régionales et des
trésors de production invraisemblable
mais c'était quand même plutôt plus
marrant ce qu'on mangeait chez mes
parents et savait plus de goût donc oui
j'avais des camarades qui venait chez
moi qui est
différent et c'est là que j'ai pris
conscience du fait que c'était
particulier c'était une identité
particulière ce n'est pas mieux ni moins
bien c'était différent c'était en tout
cas beaucoup plus métissée que la
plupart des enfants ou des jeunes de mon
agent et ça c'est sûr or aujourd'hui
tout ça est beaucoup plus mélangées
toutes ces influences justement
européenne qu'on soit en belgique en
france ou ailleurs on a à peu près tous
les produits
dans un magasin qui est pas trop loin de
chez nous ça c'est l'évolution de
l'europe aussi finalement qui se traduit
à travers cette possibilité
d'approvisionnement et ce goût parce
qu'on a découvert en fait avec la
construction européenne plein de
nouveaux produits le fait d'être en
contact avec avec aussi des personnes
qui ont d'autres traditions d'autres
cultures mais c'est vraiment ça qui est
passionnant moi je trouve dans l'idée de
l'europe c'est ce ce voyage permanent
est le fait que les frontières soient
poreuse et qu'on absorbe et que ça
ressurgit sous une forme nouvelle et ça
vous pour tout ça vaut pour la culture
ça vaut pour les comportements ça vaut
pour la mode ça vaut pour tous les
champs de la création et ça vaut
beaucoup je trouve pour la cuisine sur
tout a beaucoup changé moi je me
souviens il ya une quinzaine d'années
quand j'ai commencé à écrire un pas
majeur à cuisiner là et la restauration
je crois que la france avait quand même
un côté un peu un peu fermé un peu
disons qu'il y avait une scène de
bistrot assez passionnante la
gastronomie était intéressante c'était
vraiment un creuset d'excellence comme
elle l'a toujours été je trouvais à
l'époque avec
10 15 20 euros en poche on s'amusait pas
des masses quoi les frontières étaient
encore assez fermé c'est vraiment je
trouve que l'évolution et le le fruit de
ces de ces flux migratoires de cette
circulation
de effectivement de quelque chose qui a
pu marcher à londres ou à berlin une
manière de cuisiner
et la résine c'est de la culture a
qu'une c'est complètement la culture
c'est la culture c'est la pop culture
c'est de la pratique
socioculturel c'est fatalement la
culture c'est le reflet de d'un creuset
d'influencés c'est un lieu où on raconte
une histoire manger faire à manger c'est
vraiment raconter les histoires ses
livres un peu de soi même c'est un récit
intime où beaucoup plus large cessez
complètement la culture à mon sens c'est
ce qui est intéressant quand je les
entends que c'est qu'en fait ça permet
de parler de l'europe autrement parce
que oui à l'europe aujourd'hui on
associe parfois des choses moyennement
glamour on voit des institutions on voit
au parlement on voit on voit des
directives qui sont d'ailleurs parfois
contraignantes pour les chefs ou pour
les aidants culteurs pour les paysans
mais le fait d'en parler avec avec la
nourriture bas ça donne tout d'un coup
une autre idée de l'europe de son
terroir de manière un peu global am est
complètement effectivement c'est
tellement un lieu de partage la cuisine
même si pour arriver à cette cuisine
effectivement là tout ce que vous dites
qui me paraît vraiment très très
importants
il n'y a pas de cuisine sans produit
c'est vraiment de l'enfant sage de
portes ouvertes quand je dis ça mais il
n'y a pas de bonne cuisine sans produit
responsable vertueux or les paysans et
les paysannes qui travaillent de cette
façon justement très responsable très
engagé au plus près des ressources en
essayant précisément qu'ils soient
éleveurs qui soit cultivateurs en
essayant de préserver voire de créer un
maximum de biodiversité
ces personnes là qui ont soit des petits
cheptel en écho pâturages soit qui
travaillent sans aucun intrant chimique
en appliquant des principes de par la
culture ou d'un gros foresterie par
exemple ces gens là ce sont les plus
embêtés et les moins aidés par la
réglementation européenne là je
schématise un peu je rentre pas dans les
textes que je me prétends en aucun cas
être un expert du sujet mais la
politique agricole commune n'est
clairement pas l'ami des petits paysans
tels qu'ils m'en font le récit mais la
richesse invraisemblable de ses terroirs
l'engagement de jeunes paysans qui
parfois on fait autre chose avant de
s'installer quand il arrive à accéder au
foncier parce qu'on sait à quel point
c'est pas simple d'accéder à des terres
quand on veut s'installer mais quand ils
y arrivent souvent ils ont fait autre
chose j'ai rencontré des paysans qui
cultivent du pois chiche après avoir à
faire des études d'anthropologie par
exemple et qui me disent oui mais
finalement créer un écosystème reprend
d'une terre agricole c'est mettre en
pratique tout un ensemble de tout un
corpus théorique que j'ai appris tout au
long de mes études mais simplement là là
je me lève le matin je vais rarement
créé de la valeur écrire la richesse et
puis favoriser la naissance ou la
préservation de goût subtil variés
différents tout ça à la faveur de ce
travail d'engagement incroyable se
retrouve dans l'assiette et se retrouve
dans l'assiette
préparé par des jeunes chefs qui voyage
grâce à l'europe qui sous peu être allé
voir un copain
ça aide un bourrin autret think i en
passant par la sardaigne
ils se rencontrent dans le vignoble chai
des vignerons anglais ou suédois
installés en france et ouvre des
bouteilles ils boivent un vin également
un vin engagé un vin en biodynamie
nature un vin qui ressemble à celui ou
celle qui la produit ils s'attablent il
partage des connaissances et ça donne
lieu ensuite dans leur restaurant à
quelque chose qui est un feu d'artifice
au plus près du produit mais portant
l'empreinte de celui ou celle qui signe
ce plat mois sur ça n'a jamais été aussi
passionnant que de discuter avec des
chefs et le goûter leur cuisine à des
prix en plus qu'ils n'ont jamais été
aussi abordables il faut pouvoir se
payer ça reste ça reste comme ça s'est
démocratisé ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir comment on voit ça de
l'extérieur de l'europe aussi mis parce
que du coup c'est peut-être là qu'on
perçoit plus l'unité qui a malgré tout
entre tous et ses terroirs parce que vu
d'asie vue vue du continent américain la
gastronomie européenne la culture
européenne c'est quand même quelque
chose encore même si tout voyage
beaucoup plus la gastronomie en robe
européenne reste quelque chose qui
attire d'ailleurs encore beaucoup de
vocations beaucoup de chefs de jeunes
chefs américains chinois japonais
viennent toujours se forme en france
alors on a beaucoup de jeunes chefs
français qui vont se former à l'étranger
aussi les frontières encore une fois
sont devenus plus mouvantes ça circule
beaucoup plus mais ça reste une école
d'excellence et puis on continue d'avoir
en europe des tables vers lesquelles
convergent des jeunes talents du monde
entier qui ont envie de se former de se
frotter à ces savoirs et c'est vers sic
la très grande diversité
de productions j'allais dire culturel le
production agriculture elle
fait que oui on nous regarde je crois de
je crois depuis les états unis où depuis
l'asie au sens très large de
l'expression en se disant quand même en
europe ils font les font les choses bien
encore alors au delà des des saveurs au
delà de ce qu'on mange comment est ce
que vous vous définissez vos elvira
masson est ce que vous sentez européenne
oui je me sens vraiment européenne alors
vous arrive de vous présenter comme ça
ou en tout cas si vous réfléchissez à
l'identité qui est la vôtre je crois
vraiment que je suis une enfant de ces
éducation européenne alors un peu malgré
moi aussi je pense que mes parents avant
moi ont cru assez fort à cette idée
d'europe quand une fois c'était pas
nommé mais ma mère suédoise qui a vécu
en angleterre qui est arrivé dans les
années 60 en france comme beaucoup de
femmes suédoises de cette époque là on
vous dit comme beaucoup de femmes
monsieur doit ça veut dire que beaucoup
de femmes années 60-70 qui ont quitté la
suède sans doute parce que c'est un
petit pays qui se sont installés en
angleterre aux états-unis en france
souvent pour un jeune fille au pair
c'était vraiment le parcours classique
c'était le cas de ma mère aussi jeune
fille au pair apprenant le français à
l'alliance française c'était vraiment un
parcours très classique elle a rencontré
mon père qui lui était vraiment
franco-français mais très très ouvert
sur l'europe aussi mon père a dû faire
quatre fois le tour de l'espagne en
scooter dans les 60 70 n'était pas très
courant et j'ai grandi avec ce goût de
l'europe des voyages on m'a fait sentir
en fait on m'a élevé avec l'idée que
l'europe c'était chez moi et que j'étais
certes française j'avais un passeport
français et un passeport suédois mais
que c'était pas très important tout ça
ça ne s'arrête pas à ces fausses arrière
légèrement pas à ça et oui tu es
peut-être franco suédoise mais tu es un
peu de partout d'ailleurs pendant mes
études quand il s'était agi d'avoir la
possibilité de faire erasmus en fait la
question se posait pas c'était évident
que j'allais partir étudier dans le
cadre du programme erasmus salam était
bizarre de pas le faire coiffer s'était
levé et avait osé en suède fait
une fac
pour l'éternel sino si finalement la
suite était pas un pays que je
connaissait si bien que ça parce que je
partais plus tôt en vacances ailleurs en
europe qu'en suède donc quand l'occasion
s'est présentée de pouvoir y étudier
j'ai sauté sur l'occasion il ya une
fierté d'être européenne vers midi oui
il ya vraiment une fierté d'être
européenne alors une fierté construire
un peu sur un paradoxe à la je véhicule
les idées que j'ai grandi qui était donc
cette chose induites qu'on avait
beaucoup de chances d'être européen je
venais d'un foyer clairement européen
hispanophone anglophone moi on m'a fait
étudié l'allemand j'ai appris l'anglais
puis j'ai pas tellement le choix m'a dit
tu feras l'allemand et je pense
qu'inconsciemment c'était un peu quand
même cette idée de construction
européenne franco allemande le mur est
tombé quand j'avais 12-13 ans était
quand même super fort la chute du mur on
était collée à la télé je lisais la
presse anglaise beaucoup on parlait
anglais on parle espagnol à la maison et
puis voilà on me faisait sentir que
c'était un terrain de jeu et j'avais
intérêt à être un peu à la hauteur de la
chance qui m'était offerte il y avait ce
côté aussi je pense quand même de
parents nés à la fin de la guerre
quand même sans que ce soit vraiment dû
me parlait pas de la guerre mais par où
on était tous d'enfants mais c'était
quand même des enfants de l'immédiate
après guerre
il y avait quand même cette idée que
c'était vraiment important l'europe
aussi pour ce à quoi une europe
protectrice de ses enfants qui éviterait
les conflits à venir alors après avec
les succès les échecs que ça peut être
mais veut une espèce de grand central et
quand même quand la suède a intégré
l'union européenne ont omis de l'absence
d'un 95 vous vous souvenez de ce moment
parce que je m'en souviens un peu aux
minimes et comme quelque chose de
parfaitement naturel
voilà ça aurait pu arriver plus tôt mais
je m'en sors je me souviens du moment je
m'en souviens pas comme d'un moment très
solennel ou très émouvant s'était il
était temps et heureusement que ça
arrivait mais il ya deux branches qui se
réunissait deux oui c'est vrai mais
c'est ce qui m'a rendu d'ailleurs si
triste moi je me considère comme très
chaud j'ai dû être anglaise dans une
autre vie je suis très j'ai un tropisme
anglais très fort dans mes goûts
culinaires aussi bizarrement je suis une
des rares personnes en france qui adore
laquelle la gastronomie anglaise j'adore
la cuisine engage tous qu'on mange super
bien en angleterre c'est vrai que le
break it m'a beaucoup attristé vraiment
gs j'ai vraiment été très très très
abattu ça m'a fait de la peine
sentimentalement en fait plus qu
économiquement jeu j'ai été peiné arte
dans une sensibilité je pense une un
sentiment de l'europe fort
alors cette europe c'est un eldorado
pour pour beaucoup de gens encore
aujourd'hui et on on avait envie dans
cette collection d'interviews de montrer
cette image parce que l'europe c'est
c'est ça aussi aujourd'hui c'est une
europe qui parfois se referme
un peu peur de l'extérieur qui voit
l'extérieur comme une menace j'avais
envie de vous faire réagir et c'est
vraiment une image qui me glace mahfal
douglas tous ce qui me glace aussi c'est
l'idée que cette image puisse finir par
nous un différé parce qu'on l'a beaucoup
vu circuler je me suis ça provoque une
réaction à chaud d'émotion mais mais que
fait-on effectivement moi je suis
évidemment pour une europe de l'accueil
de tous je suis pour une europe
qui est plus solidaire par rapport à
évidemment plus solidaire toujours plus
solidaire dire ça encore une fois j'en
fais un peu une porte ouverte c'est je
sais que c'est frappé aussi un peu
au-dessous de la naïveté je mesure bien
mais je suis pour une europe qui
accueille tous ses enfants et qu'il est
qui les accueillent dans de bonnes
conditions des conditions il pouvoir
s'épanouir à la fois dans le respect du
droit parce que l'euro c'est aussi
finalement le métissage avec les
influences qui viennent absolue en
dehors de ses frontières salue mans
l'europe sont son devoir c'est
d'accueillir
de tous pays
des personnes qui n'ont pas eu la même
chance qui n'ont pas eu la même
éducation que nous dans des conditions
qui se doivent d'être descente peut pas
accueillir des personnes dans des
mouroirs on doit leur donner des droits
donc c'est oui je sais j'ai pas grand
chose de plus à dire que ça en dehors du
fait que j'aspire vraiment à une europe
qui soit la plus accueillante possible
quoi dans des conditions possibles j'ai
envie de terminer cet entretien elvira
masson avec un petit questionnaire pour
voir quelles sont les images finalement
que vous associer à cette europe un
paysage s'il fallait définir un paysage
européen quel serait-il pour votre âge
vous faire une réponse hyper compliqué
est-ce que c'est impossible d'en choisir
un et j'adore les paysages moi j'adore
compte empêcher une grande rêveuse une
grande contemplatrice alors
j'imaginerais une espèce de d'hybrides
qui serait composé de tous les paysages
que j'aime il y aura du bocage normand
il y aurait de la côte de granit brave
une image pour vous est ce que ça
pourrait être
super bien vu c'est ça il ya de la crécq
azur il ya de la forêt très dense il ya
du village perché j'adore les villages
perchés
il ya du lac qu est ce qu il yad autres
il ya des saisons changeantes on voit un
peu des feuilles roussies à l'automne
j'adore les ai je trouve que l'ailé lé
paysage de bocage ses terres pas trop
remembrer c'est justement le le symbole
d'une vie végétale et d'une d'une vie
paysanne respectueuse des ressources
avec beaucoup de biodiversité sur qui a
rien de plus triste qu'une plaine qui a
été complètement remembrer en
monoculture avec des sols mort est
forcément beaucoup de chimie donc je
suis trop contente que vous ayez mis des
haies des petites parcelles et puis
voilà la richesse de l'europe cette
beauté je sais pas unique ce mélange de
pierres de terre de mer azur et j'espère
vraiment de forêt de but diversité qui
vont pouvoir être réservés finalement la
vraie chasse et ça c'est qu'on peut pas
le résumer à ouais c'est ça un paysage
mais c'est la beauté de cette europe 1
alors s'il fallait définir l'europe avec
un tableau j'ai choisi une femme artiste
qui s'appelle dora maar dora maar a été
entre autres choses la maîtresse de
picasso c'est une grande photo gr et
koné surréaliste magnifique elle est
européenne au sens elle est vraiment le
pur produit d'une europe des années 20
30 40 c'est à dire de père hongrois
émigré en france
elle a vécu à londres à barcelone à
paris elle a beaucoup voyagé il ya des
études libres et voilà et ça cette
oeuvre là bas ça pour être effectivement
une allégorie de l'europe et je voulais
choisir une femme artiste et femmes
artistes qui a été pas mal écrasé par le
génie qu'était picasso qui n'avaient pas
une passion pour l'épanouissement
artistique de ses compagnes françoise
gilot non plus n'a pas tellement eu voix
au chapitre et je trouve formidable
qu'on redécouvre le travail génial des
femmes de picasso à commencer par dora
maar nous le travail mais pat et oui
c'est pas mal dans l'ordre le thème non
c'est pas mal de tête alors si l'europe
était un homme et culinaires ça c'est
une question pour vous c'est vraiment
difficile j'en ai quand même choisir que
je trouve symboliquement intéressant qui
est le kebab kebab c'est un mot
d'origine turque c'est une une brochette
mais le kebab au sens du sandwich qu'on
mange quand on a vraiment super fins que
et qu'on a envie de se goinfrer de
calories de viande chaude dégoulinante
dans du pain c'est une création
allemande des années 60 70 je crois mais
c'est un turc qui a créé ce sandwich à
berlin c'est vraiment un symbole le
street food qui peut absolument abjecte
s'y est fait que de la viande de
mauvaise qualité du mauvais pain mais
qui peut être très très bon aussi s'il
est bien fait et j'aime bien cette idée
de cultures très populaire de choses
qu'on mange en a eu et puis si je fait
que vous alliez l'arbre aux poils parce
que c'est pas tout à fait l'image de la
gastronomie justement
on a bien qu'on me la suis plus dans les
usages du quotidien et j'aime bien
l'idée effectivement d'avoir répondu en
choisissant quelque chose de très
accessible on peut se payer quel que
soit le montant de son
de son investissement en fin d une
porte- fait dans les pas bons on peut
mettre un peu de tout et mais
l'interpréter différemment en fonction
des endroits aussi partout en europe
voilà on connaît pas forcément l'origine
mais c'est turcot berline européen quoi
à l'air aurait terminé avec de la
musique s'il fallait changer l'hymne
européen pour une raison ou pour une
autre et qu'on disait au revoir à l'aude
à la joie de beethoven qu'est ce que
vous suggérez rayé je suggère le plus
grands morceaux de musique de tous les
temps qui est vraiment un morceau de
musique électro que j'adore avec tout le
monde adore severi disco des daft punk
ah ben voilà je trouve que ça commence
presque comme un morceau de bach et
c'est un morceau de génie de pure
électro qui contient mille musique en
elle-même
c'est un morceau très introspectif et à
la fois très dense très riche très
dansant grave et dansant à la fois
je le trouve
joyeux et triste à la fois j'ai pu me
lever et danser en même temps de mettre
plonge en soi même toutes vos multiples
se trouve multiculturelle je trouve
complet et chant qu'il est vraiment à
l'image de ce que devrait être l'europe
je trouve ça magnifique ça
non je confirme on va le laisser un peu
d'ailleurs pour terminer cette émission
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir accepté ce
grand entretien et veyrat masson et de
nous avoir parlé de votre idée de
l'europe et de vos origines de votre
culture européenne merci mille fois
[Musique]